yeah i saw like uh was it like a
deadline article about like your you've
got like a series based on your book
about ufos and then now there's like a
subsequent series to that yeah so
legendary picked up um my books called
secret machines it's like these 700 page
novels that are about ufos uh story
about ufos but it's all governments all
like military industrial complex think
like area 51 cia department of defense
um and then their counterparts in other
countries and intermixed with that is
some of the things flying around are are
totally different entirely you know um
and so that's it's a big deal because
this is the this is the true story of
ufos of what's been going on with our
government and everything else so i
think that
there there's two things that really
strike me as crazy about the the
developments with the ufos number one
it's crazy that the government
uh is all of a sudden just sort of
saying yeah the ufos are real you know
there's like you know all this
like the government acknowledged you
know we did that i did that that's why
they're doing that
but what's even i would say i sound like
a dick when i say that but i'm like
that's why i have there's a whole story
here but keep going it's it's crazy to
me that the the government's
acknowledging ufos are very real and
it's even crazier that that news comes
out and like everyone's like oh yeah
they're all like yeah but interest rates
are gnarly and like [ __ ] covet you're
like
what the [ __ ] like that's how a lot of
us so what happened was is that book
secret machines i i wrote that with an
author and i started my company to the
stars and we're going to publish a book
and then when i put it in there because
i started ufos like 20 years and i was
like
i figured out what's going on not just
like the [ __ ] you read or thing like
i figured out like what's going on and i
was like
[ __ ] if i put this out there and open my
big mouth i might get in a lot of
trouble so i should probably go ask for
some permission so i spent like a long
time working my way in
and then i got into a group of
people and and
they brought me in and um i was given
all the permission so then i come out
with a book and i go on national radio
and all this [ __ ] well apparently that
group didn't really talk to another
group of some other three letter places
and those other places got really
[ __ ] pissed because uh here's this
[ __ ] rockstar kid like
like telling the biggest national
security secrets that we got period and
so they
came and they were like
we need to know who the [ __ ] you are and
who the [ __ ] you're talking to and all
this crazy like ed snowden type [ __ ] and
i was like hold on and i had to explain
that like all this really classified
crazy [ __ ] i figured that out on my own
i don't have anyone passing me like
i'm sorry man i was tripping balls i
know i had to get them all sorry i was
stoned one night and i just kind of
[ __ ] did a puzzle and i was like
whoopsie you know so what happened then
was
um
the you know hillary clinton was running
for presidency against uh i guess it was
against trump and uh and john podesta
was her campaign manager okay at the
time he was also senior adviser to obama
so i was holding conversations with
podesta to get to obama and i had
two multi-star generals from space
command and the head of lockheed martin
skunk works that skunk works built area
51 um their elite engineering division i
had them all on this like [ __ ] emails
and we're setting up these conference
calls and stuff well
hillary clinton's campaign got hacked by
the russians wikileaks and it outed all
this [ __ ] about podesta and her
and what happened with that was when
all these news journalists were pouring
through wikileaks to see what spilled
from hillary's campaign they found these
[ __ ] emails with me and podesta
talking to these generals about ufos
so wall street journal threw that onto
the wall street journal
and then i was like
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] and i'm like out there
like [ __ ] erasing computers and doing
all this different i didn't know what to
do um and at that time all these other
government people that came out
let me ask you why would that be a
problem for you if
i mean there's no there's nothing wrong
with exchanging emails with uh that
wasn't the issue the more of the issue
was like
the more of the issue their insecurity
just all these guys are
holding the secrets of the universe
and it's a much
what would happen in conversations is i
just knew things so i would say it they
might not say something back but i'm
kind of thinking that any of those
conversations should not be [ __ ]
poured over by anybody okay that wants
to just come in and just like make a
name for themselves at the bureau you
know
so i'm just like tripping like [ __ ] and
then i could see that yeah so
what happened though is it gave me all
this credibility because then all of a
sudden all these other people in the
government knew that i was like hanging
around with some big boys so they all
came out and said there's a better way
to do what you're doing and then that's
when my company was a lot just me it
became something bigger and so
the company
came out to the public founded by myself
one of the heads of the cia and the head
physicist for the ufo program and then i
hired the program director the guy that
ran the ufo program and then i brought
on another like eight people from the
dod and the cia so they're all part of
my company and the first thing we did
was take those videos to the new york
times and out the program
and then we went and spent two years
briefing all the committees in the
senate and congress and the director the
office of director of national
intelligence so now you're seeing
hearings the dod admitted ufo's real the
navy admit that's all us the hearings
that congress and the ufo the uap
task force that's all that we started
all of that and it all started with me
just being a little punk rock kid just
going i'm gonna [ __ ] do this not
really knowing what i was playing with
you know so
i mean it's super impressive and and i
love how
well you communicate to your your
ability to tell stories is is really
well thank you he's a highly evolved
being i'm just i'm just a very spiritual
dude man yeah i love it um
can you help us understand what what's
the
significance of the ufos they're not
coming from
well i should say this way the
significance of ufos is is multiple
parts but
number one it's not what you think it is
it's not coming from other planets the
evidence doesn't suggest that
interdimensional yes and the reason is
because time is
time is parallel it's not linear or it's
not like we we start here and go forward
in time
time is side by side which means
everything in the past and the future is
existing in this moment but within
different frequencies
so
a civilization that's at the end of
their technological cycle
could build a submarine that changes its
voltage and materializes in that same
location just into our timeline
and then [ __ ] it's crazy that that
was well articulated i like that have
you ever had any like glitches in the
matrix where like like yes time sped up
for you or like i've had that a couple
times weird things so um
like this yeah yeah but but when it was
when i got more into this so so there's
a consciousness aspect to this like you
have to think of like um
consciousness is like it's like the mind
of god you know it's not a dude in a
toga with a crown of thorns making
jupiter you know it's like everything
you see is one band of frequencies the
highest frequency is light unified mind
the lowest frequency would be blackness
absent absent absence of love absence of
whatever and in physical matter
somewhere right in the middle right so
you have the ability to tune up higher
or tune down lower and behavior and all
these things and time and it all [ __ ]
comes together but what it means also is
that your brain
is what's called um a transducer you're
an antenna consciousness it's what i was
saying to uh
duncan trussell yeah duncan trussell
so you create matter
and when you think something it creates
it it's and you are not you're not
reactionary to your environment you're
actually proactive and you just don't
know it so it really matters what you
choose to see and feel because that's
literally what's being created for you
and people don't know this [ __ ] so when
you're like really into some crazy [ __ ]
the universe will start creating things
and we just think it's paranormal like
um for example at ucla they were
studying poltergeist events and they
found out that you could see a book move
on the shelf and it scares you but if
you see a book move on the shelf and it
scares the [ __ ] out of you that book
will then fly off the shelf and try and
hit you so the more scared you get the
more [ __ ] starts happening and they
didn't know why well the reason is is
you're a transducer of your environment
you're an antenna plugging into all
these frequencies and once you go oh
that book is moving it'll move
you know so it's [ __ ] crazy it's like
our universe it's just not what we think
it is and and the whole thing with ufos
is that they're [ __ ] around with us
because of that you know is it not
like i
would not
think of ufo
as like a vehicle right which aliens are
going to travel in
yeah
should we not should we not be using the
term aliens yeah alien is hard only
because it's like
that that makes us think it's coming
from mars or some [ __ ] or a different
planet these are more like entities
these are more like a lot of them are um
there's a lot there's like clones that
are like just [ __ ] like you think we
made dolly the sheep and we think that
we're like you think that's all we've
done in the 60s we cloned a sheep
we might be a little bit more advanced
than that so what is something else
that's super advanced doing ai and
creating things that can fly around and
tamper well are they little program bots
well where's like the mainframe well
maybe the ship is alive in a mainframe
biological organism but it's metal and
whatever but there's an intelligence to
it because it's so advanced okay so the
so the theory that they they started
showing up at the time we did nuclear
weapons they're not here to protect us
they're because that would be
like it's not interdimensional that
would be from like outer space no
they're protecting their dimensional
because the one thing we found out is
that the emp wave from a nuclear blast
kind of travels through multiple
dimensions
so it's like that that energy is [ __ ]
up whatever's in that location and maybe
those people like what the [ __ ] was that
let's materialize into that other
timeline and get those [ __ ] to
stop but the reality is too is ufo's
have been around forever like you're
talking biblical you're talking
religions you're talking about the
pyramids the pyramids you're talking the
star of bethlehem is not a star the sun
is big the star bethlehem is like a
little ball of light that three dudes on
horses followed for days and it hovered
over a manger so think about that what
is that ezekiel's wheels you know fatima
and portugal all these religious events
are always the same thing and you got to
then go well what are they doing what is
happening from that well we start cults
we go crazy we create different
religions we have different belief
systems we get really scared because
they prophesize the end of the world
they tell you that if you do something
wrong you're going to burn in hell for
eternity but if you listen to what that
voice is in your head that's god so do
that and then someone hears a burning
bush and they go and start a religion
you know it's like holograms and
technologies and and
making people
not
be together you know making us think
that there's a dude
like allah or jesus that created the
universe versus
source intelligence such as like your
bandwidth your fiber optic cable just to
like consciousness which is like the one
power that powers the atom that's that
permeates everything and we're all from
it but as long as we think it's a dude
and that group over there thinks it's a
different dude we're going to hate each
other and we don't really evolve and we
don't really grow spiritually you know
i'm sure you've heard the story
i went down the rabbit hole with uh you
know like
they brought people to alpha centauri to
live like 13 people yeah and serpo is
that true i mean what is that different
than like what's going on now like is
are stories like that true or i don't
buy those i i at all but i do know some
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] where like
you it makes you kind of wonder about
the other stuff so
for example there i was um
there's a document that leaked
that described something coming from
another planet and then it hit like a
meteor and then it all came down and
then we retrieved these bodies in the
craft and whatever so i knew this
document and then i was in a meeting i
can't say with who and
what it was all about but
i found out during that meeting that
that was misinformation the part about
the media and coming from another planet
and then they leaked the document and
the whole point was for us to keep
thinking these are coming from planets
and [ __ ] um because it's a lot less
scary you know to think well they're
super far away so it's hard for them to
get here you know but the reality is is
like
the the misinformation placed in
documents that are already leaked on
purpose is to slowly inoculate us and to
be okay with things over time it's a lot
easier to go well they're not coming
from other planets they're coming from
here but you already knew about them so
it's not as scary it's not too much
thrown on you at once
but the the absurdity that comes along
with this stuff
is insane like in the sense of like
dude i've been told so many [ __ ]
stories there's like [ __ ] where things
just show up and um
and they look you know totally human and
then you turn around and it's not even
there but you're on a ship in the middle
of the atlantic and you're on an
aircraft carrier and it's like there's a
human standing there telling you to get
the [ __ ] out of the area and then you
turn around and that [ __ ] human's not
even there you know so you're kind of
going well did we go to another planet
like those things what i would say is
there is potential that something like
that happened but i would say 70 percent
of what's in there is probably untrue or
something i think that there are things
on other planets but i think that what's
really going on is like space time they
call it space time is because
if you
light a flashlight that light travels
for infinity so if you were just like
when we see a star they always tell you
you're seeing like
we're seeing what happened like 30 000
years ago because that light just got
here so we're essentially seeing
the beginning we're seeing the same star
but we're seeing a different point in
time than where it's at but we're
looking at it and that's the idea that i
think in space
the way things stretch out with light is
the way everything exists all in one
moment so i don't know how much planet
to planet [ __ ] transportation is
going on i don't doubt it but what i do
know is the things that are
materializing here are doing it with
frequency and timelines and stuff
yeah when you
said materialize in a different
you know time
yeah like and describing the parallel
timelines
that uh was so digestible oh yeah
i was able to really like
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude